el abierto de australia comienza este
lunes y se van reduciendo las
posibilidades de que el número uno del
tenis participe en la competición
el ministro de inmigración canceló la
visa de novak djokovic este viernes
australia revocó la visa del tenista por
segunda vez argumentando que es de
interés público dado que no está
vacunado contra el kobe 19 las
autoridades quieren detenerlo este
sábado por la mañana lo que puede
conllevar la deportación del serbio y la
prohibición de que vuelva a obtener un
visado en los próximos tres años
los abogados de djokovic buscan apelar
la decisión el deportista tiene cita
inmigración a las 8 de la mañana hora
australiana y su expulsión no puede
ejecutarse antes de una nueva audiencia
pero para poder jugar en el torneo la
justicia debería emitir una sentencia
favorable durante el fin de semana en
circunstancias normales
djokovic sería el claro favorito para
ganar la competición y sería su victoria
número 21 de un gran slam un récord en
el tenis masculino pero esta saga ha
eclipsado la competición y levantado
críticas por parte de otros jugadores
y soy alguien que nadie creería que
puedo venir a australia sin estar
vacunado emirates
sin seguir los protocolos que se me
piden todos los protocolos desde yemen
en un primer momento la visa del serbio
fue revocada el 6 de enero poco después
de su llegada a melbourne entre
interrogantes sobre la excepción vacunal
que se le había otorgado previamente
pasó cinco días detenido en un hotel
hasta que un juez determinó que los
agentes fronterizos no habían seguido el
procedimiento correcto la trama tiene un
componente político dado que el gobierno
es consciente de que permitir la
estancia a djokovic sería impopular
entre una población que ha vivido bajo
el confinamiento más largo del mundo